FRANCESCO: Welcome.
How are you guys doing so far?
AUDIENCE: Good.
FRANCESCO: Having fun?
Lots of things happening here.
At some point, I thought they
wanted to have me base jump
into this room.
Crazy stuff.
My name is Francesco, and I'm
the engineering manager for a
cloud messaging team
in Android.
How many of you guys
in this room have
experience with C2DM?
Android cloud--
a lot of you.
OK, I'm in the right room.
So let me start giving you a
brief introduction about this
service, which we launched
in Labs two years ago
at Google I/O 2010.
Now, very simply, what C2DM
allows you is for your server
to send a message to
your application
on any Android device.
What C2DM allows for
is what we call the
send-to-sync mechanism.
Let me explain with
an example.
We have a news server that wants
to deliver an update on
a topic to the devices
of its subscribers.
So the server goes ahead,
sends the message.
And when the application
receives it, all it does is to
connect back to the
news server and
grab for the new data.
Now, the beauty of this
mechanism is that it allows
the application to avoid the
nuisance of having to
continuously poll to check if
there even is new data.
This saves battery life.
Another thing that C2DM does is
that if the server sends a
message, and the device is
offline, it holds onto the
message and delivers
it as soon as the
device comes back online.
Now, C2DM messages are not
really meant to carry the
content with them.
What they're mostly used for
is to say, look, there's
something new.
Go check it out.
So if the news server sends
three messages, which refers
to an update on the very same
topic, and the device is
offline, it would be really
silly for us to deliver all
three of them when it
comes back online.
Because the application will
continuously connect to the
server and grab for the
very same data.
So C2DM does something that
we call collapsing.
When the device comes
back online, we
deliver only one of these.
This saves data and allows
for an easy application
development.
Because, since the server takes
care of this use case,
all that our application needs
to do is, every time I get a
message, I'm going to connect
to my server.
Now, send-to-sync is a simple
and flexible mechanism.
However, much can be done
to optimize for all the
use cases out there.
And speaking about improvement,
let's see how
today we get started
with C2DM.
So we need a Google account so
that we can go ahead and
create and manage a client
login token.
At this point, we can compile a
sign-up form, and wait until
we receive an activation
email confirmation.
At this stage, we are granted
some initial quota.
Now, the more we develop the
application, the more users we
get, hopefully.
The more messages we send,
the more quota we need.
We come back, ask for
more quota, and
so on, and so forth.
Without any doubt there is a lot
that we can do to improve
this process.
Nonetheless, this service has
seen a lot of traction.
Along with all the applications
of you guys that
before raised your hands,
we tens of thousands of
applications that actively are
using this service every
single day.
C2DM processes billions of
messages every single day.
Which is kind of impressive
for a service
that launched in Labs.
We were also kind of impressed
by the amount of great
feedback that you
guys provided.
So we decided to bring cloud
messaging to the next level.
So today, I'm very excited
because I finally get to
announce our new service,
Google Cloud
Messaging for Android.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCESCO: We specifically
designed this
service to make it simple.
So how do you get started,
for example?
You go to the Google Developer
console, click Enable GCM, and
you're done.
There's no more client login
that you have to care about,
no more sign-up form or waiting
for activations.
And best of them all, we got
rid completely of quota.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCESCO: We're launching this
service because we want
to make it powerful.
We want to address a lot more
use cases out there.
Let's go back to our news
server example.
What that application wants to
do is to deliver that update
on that topic to a big bunch
of its subscribers in one
time, with one request.
And now we can do that.
A voice over IP or a video
chat application wants to
deliver an incoming call request
if, and only if, the
user at the other end of the
line is online right now.
Otherwise there's no point.
And GCM makes this
really simple.
And instant messaging
applications, they don't
really have a syncing problem.
They have a messaging problem.
Send-to-sync is a bit
tight for them.
They want to deliver the content
of the chat message
straight down to the
application and
be done with it.
And now you can.
And finally, we've been working
really hard to make
this service fast.
But how fast can GCM get?
We take 4.7 milliseconds
to send a message.
Now that I've given you the
flashy numbers, I'm going to
read through the disclaimers.
This means 4.7 milliseconds is
when GCM receives the message
'til the time that GCM
sends the message.
It does not include the latency
due to the network
between the server and the
client for one simple reason--
I don't have a say in that.
And second, this works if the
news server is here in the
Moscone Center, and the user
is probably in Ocean Beach,
San Francisco.
But globally, what is the
average latency that GCM
introduces, with those billions
of messages including
use cases like a news server in
Munich, Germany, and a user
in Taipei, Taiwan.
GCM has quite a bit of routing
to do in that case.
Well, globally, GCM still takes
less than 1/10 of a
second to process the message.
The problem is, you're not
going to notice this.
But the best part of them all
is that all this is still
completely free.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE].
So let's dive into this.
Since the European championship
is going on, and
Italy just won, of course,
let's say that we want to
build the best football
application ever--
or soccer.
So, first thing first, what
we're going to do is to
deliver score updates in real
time during live events.
And to do this, we're
going to use GCM.
So let me give you a high-level
overview of how
this system works.
Well, first of all, our football
application needs to
tell the server that
we want to use GCM.
To do this, it sends a
registration request, and GCM
server generates a Registration
ID for us.
Now, what is a Registration
ID?
You can consider it as an
address for this application,
on this device.
The football app sends the
address to the server, so when
it wants to send a message,
it can tell GCM where
to deliver it to.
Now let's say that for some
unknown reason, our users want
to uninstall our app.
The GCM server doesn't know
yet that the app is gone.
So when the football
server sends a
message, it sends it down.
Now the GCM framework on
the device realizes,
oops, the app is gone.
So it heads back to the server,
invalidates this address.
From this moment on, every
single message that the
football server sends, it
bounces back with an error of
"Device Not Registered." If you
get this type of error,
it's a good thing to get rid
of the Registration ID from
your database.
So now that we have a high-level
picture of how the
system works, let's go ahead
and implement this.
Remember when I said that all
you need to do is to go to the
Developer Console and click
Enable Google Cloud Messaging
for Android?
If you do so, you'll end
up on a page like this.
We only need two things here,
the project ID up there and
the API key down there.
And you can consider these
two as a username
and password pair.
Just grab them, and you're
done for good with this.
So we go ahead and start writing
some code finally.
Let's start with the application
on the device.
Three simple steps.
Number one, we said we
want to register.
To do this, we send an intent
to the GCM framework, which
then talks to the server and
generates the ID for us.
So how do we send this intent?
Now, bear with me, because
the code can get a
bit complicated here.
With the GCM client library we
just released on the SDK as
open source code, the line in
red is all you need to write.
So you call the register
function and pass in the
Project ID.
Now, make sure that the Project
ID is correct because
that's the only authorized
sender that can deliver
messages to this one
application.
But perhaps I oversimplified
the code a bit.
Because if you leave the code in
this state, every time the
user clicks on the application,
we're going to do
this registration dance
over and over again.
To fix this, we add
one line of code.
The getRegistrationId gives us
an empty string if we did not
register yet, so we should
go ahead and do so.
Or it returns the Registration
ID, in which case we are done.
And we can proceed to
our second step.
Now the server is done
generating our
Registration ID.
It sends it to the framework,
which then delivers it to us
via an intent.
So all we need to do is to
listen for this intent.
And here is how we do that.
Extremely simple, we extend
the GCMBaseIntentService
class, and we override the
onRegistered function.
Now this function gives us
already a Registration ID, so
we take it and give
it to our server.
But since we are here, there are
two things that we want to
listen for, registrations
and messages.
So let's go ahead and see
how we grab a message.
Same exact thing, we override
the All Message Function.
If we need the payload, we
extract it from the intent.
And now it's our time
to do some magic.
So we can go ahead and see
step number three,
permissions.
Well, we do want our users to
know that we are using GCM
because we are effectively
sending
messages from the cloud.
We're using data from
the network, which
is not always free.
In Jelly Bean, we made this
extremely simple, again.
It's one line of code in
the Manifest file.
You still see C2DM
written up there.
It's not a typo.
It's because we want to keep it
backwards-compatible with
Froyo-plus devices.
So let's see what we've
been checking so far.
Our application can
register with GCM.
We can receive registrations and
messages from the cloud.
And we can tell our users
that we are using
data from the network.
Nothing else to do, so we can
go ahead and have a look at
the server.
What does our server know?
So in step number two, we gave
him the Registration ID.
In the authentication slide,
we gave him the API key.
So, to send a message, what the
football server needs to
do is to perform an HTTP post
request to the GCM server and
pass in, along with the message,
the Registration ID
and the API key.
So the GCM servers get the API
key and sends it directly to
an authentication server, which
in turn responds with a
project ID--
remember, a username
and password pair.
But if you also remember step
number one, the Registration
ID contains the project ID.
We pass it into the
register function.
So GCM takes that project ID,
compares it to the one from
Auth server, and if they do
match it delivers the message
to the device, to the
application specified by the
Registration ID.
Let's have a look at an
example of a request.
In blue up there is what we're
going to put in the header of
the HTTP post request.
The content type--
GCM allows for plain
text and JSON.
Authorization key is our
password, the API key.
While in green is what we put
in the body of the message,
the Registration ID, which is
the address of the device, and
the content of the message.
So now we have a fully working
client-server application
which is able to deliver score
updates during real time--
during live events--
and we can notify our
users that Portugal
just closed the match.
This is pretty cool, but let's
make it more awesome.
Say that we want to add news
updates to our applications.
We want our users to be notified
about news of their
favorite teams, of their
favorite users.
For example, I hear that Beckham
was holding on top of
his head that giant cup.
Too bad for him it was
a Stanley Cup.
We want to deliver this
news to all his users.
And to do this, we're going
to use the message
multicasting API.
The idea is that we send one
HTTP request, with one
message, and GCM delivers it
to all the devices that we
specified at the same time.
And since this is a news update,
we also want to use
the send-to-sync mechanism.
Let's look at the request.
The first parameter in red up
there is the collapse key.
This comes from the
C2DM times.
If you remember when I said
that the news server sends
three messages, three updates
about the very same topic, and
when the device comes
back online,
only one gets delivered.
Well, this happens if GCM knows
that those messages
refer to the very same topic.
And to do so, we need
to specify the very
same collapse key.
Now below, we see the
Registration IDs.
And this time, we'll put two
on a list of them, which is
the list of all the devices that
we want GCM to deliver
this message to.
Let's have a look
at the response.
Well, GCM answers us with the
number of messages succeeded,
the number of messages that
failed, and the list, in the
same order in which we specified
the Registration IDs
in the request, with a message
ID, if it was successful, or
an error code name,
in case it failed.
So to summarize, we can send
one HTTP request, with one
message, and deliver it
to multiple devices.
And GCM allows us to
specify up to 1,000
devices per one request.
So if you look at our app, as
you can clearly see, we have a
Nexus 7 and a Galaxy Nexus,
which all of you have now.
Our application can receive the
news update at the same
time if our football server
sends one request.
But let's keep going.
We want to know what David
Beckham has to say about this
Stanley Cup.
It would be really cool if we
could add social updates
inside our application delivered
by some third-party
service that does this for us.
The idea is that our football
server will deliver a message,
a news update or a score update,
straight down to our
application, while a third-party
service will
deliver a social update
to our application.
GCM allows for this, and
it's very simple.
Let's look at the registration
code again.
In the Register Function, this
time we specify a list of
Project IDs.
These are all the authorized
senders that will be able to
deliver messages down
to our application.
When GCM receives this
registration request, it
creates one Registration ID,
which contains the list of all
the senders.
So when we listen for the
Registration ID, all we need
to do is to send it to both our
football server and to the
third-party social
update server.
So with one common Registration
ID, we allow
multiple parties to deliver
multiple different messages to
our very own application.
And GCM allows us to specify
up to 100 different Project
IDs per application.
So our football server sends
the news update, and the
social update server sends
the social update.
And both get delivered
to our app.
But let's keep going.
We want to monetize with
our application.
First, it would be cool if the
app could tell us, hey, the
match just started right now.
But second, it would be awesome
if it tells us, look,
if you go into one of these bars
which we have deals with
before the match is over, and
you show our application,
you're going to get a 25%
discount on the spiciest
chicken wings ever.
And I really love
chicken wings.
Sounds like a good deal.
The idea is that we send the
message down, but we don't
want to deliver it if
the message expires.
If we're sending this message
after the match is over, we
don't want the application
to receive it.
Obviously, the application could
see the message, the
fact that there is a time stamp
that expired, and decide
to drop it.
But why deliver in
the first place?
So GCM helps us here and
allows us to specify a
lifetime for a message.
The idea is very simple.
We send the message.
If the device is offline, and
the message expires before the
device comes back online,
well, GCM
simply gets rid of it.
Let's have a look
at the request.
The first parameter up there in
red is Time To Live, which
is how we specify the lifetime
of the message in seconds.
There's a second parameter
called Delay While Idle.
This as well comes from
the C2DM times.
It is a very nice feature.
It lets us tell the GCM server,
look, even if the
device is online, do not deliver
the message unless the
user is doing something
with it.
If it's idle in the pocket, just
do not send the message.
Do not wake up the device.
This feature is really powerful
in combination with
Time To Live because even
if the device is online,
sometimes the message could
expire because of the Delay
While Idle before it
gets delivered.
Well, let's go back
to Time To Live.
We can specify values between
zero seconds and four weeks.
If we set a value of zero, well,
what it means is that if
GCM receives the message, and
the device is online, we
deliver immediately.
If it's offline, we just
drop it on the floor.
If we do not specify any
parameter, well, GCM adds a
default value of four weeks.
The reason behind this
is really simple.
Say that you're a speaker in a
conference, like me right now.
It's your first time.
You're all tense, and your hands
are shaking, and you
drop your phone in the toilet.
Happens to everybody, right?
I think they gave us a
seven-inch tablet so it's a
bit too big to fit
in the pipes--
I save it.
So the device is offline,
and the server
keeps on sending messages.
But it's not going to
come back online.
So after four weeks, GCM decides
to do some cleanup and
clears the database.
But the best feature of them
all, the one I like the most,
is to be able to chat during
live events in real time with
users I don't know, but with
which I share the passion
about the sport.
And to do this we use the
very basic messaging
functionality of GCM.
The idea is that we want to send
the chat message with the
content straight down to
the application and
be done with it.
So if, for example, we send
three messages while the
device is offline, what we want
GCM to do is to deliver
all three of them, one after
the other, as soon as the
device comes back online.
Let's look at the request.
The simplest of them all,
Registration ID and the data
of the message.
Let's say that I went
on vacation for a
weekend, or for a week.
I went to Australia, driving
the Savannah Way.
I was lucky if I
saw a person--
definitely was not
connected online.
So when I come back, I'm
actually really scared of
turning on my device.
Who knows how much data is
sitting on the cloud, waiting
for me to just turn
on the phone?
If GCM detects this
use case, well, it
does one simple thing.
It just deletes all your data.
And instead, it creates one
little message that gets
delivered down to our
application and says, look ,
you're completely out of sync.
There is so much data waiting
for you on your server.
Just go sync yourself.
It's an angry little message.
And what it tells us is how many
messages we are behind,
how many messages have
been deleted.
And if you use our client
library, there is also a
helper function.
You override the
onDeletedMessages, and you get
this total number of
messages deleted.
So you can go ahead, connect
to your server,
and do a full sync.
But how much content does GCM
allow us to put in a message?
We are allowed to specify up to
four kilobytes of payload
per single message.
And we can send up to 100
messages, if the device is
offline, before GCM decides
to delete them and have us
trigger a full sync.
So let's pause for a bit,
and let's check what we
have seen so far.
We have been delivering news
updates with one HTTP request
to up to 1,000 devices using
the multicasting API.
We've been leveraging
third-party services' features
by adding them as authorized
senders to deliver messages to
our application.
We've been delivering events,
or messages that expire, by
using the Time To
Live parameter.
And finally we've been adding
instant messaging
functionality to our application
by using the very
basic GCM messaging API.
So with this in mind, we can
go back to our very first
feature, the one in which we
deliver score updates in real
time, and make it better by
using a combination of some of
these APIs.
In this case, I would use the
collapse key because if a team
scores twice, and then we come
online, well, only the last
message matters.
Time To Live because if the
match is over before we come
online, then we don't want
to receive any messages.
And multicasting because that
simply makes our lives easier.
So now we have this awesome
server that sends lots of
messages to lots of users,
keeping them up to date with
social updates, news updates,
score updates, and whatnot.
But what happens to all
these messages?
When the football server
sends a message to GCM,
what happens to it?
Does it get dropped, sent,
received, collapsed?
I mean, mobile networks are
pretty flaky connections.
One moment they're up, a second
later they're down.
I drive through a tunnel,
connection drops.
I exit a tunnel, back up.
How reliable is GCM?
Well, Google Cloud Messaging
has this technology we call
Reliable Message Queue, RMQ,
which sits between the server
and the GCM framework
on the device.
And what it does, it ensures
that the messages are
delivered reliably.
For example, if the server sends
a message and, right
there, when we lose the
connection, before hitting the
device, the message is gone.
Now the server swears it sent
the message, but the device
never received it.
When the connection
comes back up, the
device connects to GCM.
During the login dance, RMQ
figures out that the message
has not been delivered.
So the server goes ahead
and sends it again.
Now, ensuring message delivery,
the classic way to
do it is by ACKing a message.
Server sends a message.
The device receives
the message.
The device sends an ACK
of the message.
The server receives
the ACK and marks
the message as delivered.
But this mechanism is a bit
expensive in terms of data and
resources for us.
Because if both sides have to
send an ACK message every time
they receive one, well, we've
basically doubled the number
of messages.
So what RMQ does is a little
clever thing and implements a
variant of selective ACKing.
The high level idea here is that
both sides store a bunch
of messages, and once in a
while, we ACK the bunch.
But this optimization reveals
something, one of the biggest
strengths of GCM.
It is one that you guys don't
even need to care about
because it's transparent to the
users and to developers.
Which is why Google Cloud
Messaging is committed.
It's focused to deliver the
best user experience by
providing fresh and up to date
data for all the apps.
It is heavily optimized
for battery life.
Now let me give you a high-level
overview of some of
the features that we added to
GCM to optimize for battery.
One thing that GCM knows is
what's happening on the cloud.
It sees a lot of messages
coming from different
applications.
And if we go back to the
collapsing mechanism--
remember, the three messages on
the same update, and when
the device comes back online,
only one gets delivered.
Well, that's awesome if
the device is offline.
But what happens if the
device is online?
Does it make sense to send,
continuously, the very same
update, the same news, every
30 seconds maybe?
If GCM detects such a pattern,
well, then it decides to start
throttling this type
of message.
And by throttling, it's
a very simple thing.
We just delay the delivery
of this message.
Now delaying the delivery
achieves two things.
One, it increases the chances
of collapsing.
Let's say that we send this
update every 30 seconds.
And let's say that the
delay is two minutes.
Instead of sending four
messages, we send only one.
But second, and more
importantly, it increases the
chances of batching.
Now if we put a message in the
throttle queue, and we start a
timer, let's say two minutes.
I'm just giving random
numbers here.
And two seconds before the alarm
goes off so we can send
the message, another application
sends a different
message which we want
to throttle as well.
Well, when the alarm goes off,
we send both messages.
Because the most expensive thing
that GCM can do is to
deliver a message.
We wake up the network.
We wake up the radio.
We wake up the resources.
So if we send one message, the
best thing we can do is to
send everything that we have.
And following this idea, let's
say that we have a few
messages in the throttle queue,
and another server
sends one message that we
don't want to throttle.
It's probably a chat message,
instant message,
SMS type, or whatever.
When this message comes along,
even if the throttle queue
should keep this message for
two more minutes, we just
piggyback on this one and
deliver everything.
But we want to do
more batching.
So what if the server knew
something of the client?
What if the client tells
him, hey, I'm idle.
Now the chances that the message
from the cloud is the
one that prompts the user to
wake up the device and look at
it diminishes over time.
If we have been sending messages
from the cloud for an
idle device for up to an hour,
and the user's never reacted
to it, well, we can kind of
assume that the next message
is not the one that's going
to have the user look at
it and unlock it.
Now the best thing we can do if
we detect a similar pattern
is to batch all the messages on
the cloud and send batches
of messages once in a while.
But more, what if the device
could tell us, look,
the radio is up.
And the display's on.
Maybe the user is browsing
the web.
What a perfect moment to
send out messages.
What if it could tell us, I'm
plugged in, or battery life is
less of a concern.
Maybe data is.
So for data, what if we knew
that it is connected over
Wi-Fi rather than 4G or 3G?
Well, one is definitely
cheaper.
But all these optimizations work
really well if you're a
power user.
I have millions of
applications.
I'm a super popular guy.
I receive messages
continuously.
Well, this is really awesome.
But if I have two apps
that once in a
while send a message?
Well if my device starts
telling the
server, hey, I'm up.
I'm on radio.
I'm plugged in.
Well that's worse.
You're wasting messaging,
wasting data.
So since the server is the one
that has global knowledge of
what's happening, it's the one
that's going to tell the
device, look, now is a perfect
moment for you to tell me when
you're idle.
Or, look, now it's a perfect
moment for you to shut up.
Another thing is use cases
are different.
It varies by usage behavior.
Let's say that we
have a few apps.
And one of these sends,
once in a while, the
Delay While Idle bit.
Remember, we can send the
message, but we don't deliver
it unless the device
is unlocked.
Well, then GCM would tell the
device, hey, I need to know
when you're idle and
when you're up.
But I don't need to know that
frequently, so just tell me
you're idle five minutes in.
Only in other use cases, it
would be way better for
optimization to tell the device,
hey, let me know
you're idle the moment
the screen turns off.
This is a really cool
space where lots of
innovation is happening.
But one thing we learn here,
that our messages can be in
yet another state.
They can be sent if the
device is online.
They can be stored if the
device is offline.
They can be collapsed if the
device is offline, and another
message with the same Collapse
Key comes along.
And now they can also
be throttled.
So on an average day, for those
billions of messages
that we manage, what happens
to these messages?
Where do they fit?
Which of these categories
do they fall in?
We went ahead and analyzed our
logs and found out that on an
average day almost 55% of
messages are delivered to
online devices.
While almost 42%, they're stored
on devices, waiting for
the devices to come
back online.
2.6 are collapsed--
yes, collapsed--
and 1.2, they're throttled.
Those popular guys,
they're 1%.
We found two things.
One is that GCM does
not lose messages.
If we receive a message, we know
exactly in which of these
categories it falls.
And two, well, it would be
really awesome if our
developer's could have access
to similar stats.
So we went ahead and integrated
with the Android
Developer Console, which already
shows stats for your
applications.
But now if you login, you can
also see these type of metrics
for your GCM and C2DM
applications.
In a few weeks, Android
Developer Console will roll
out a new UI.
So let me give you a preview of
this new UI integrated with
our metrics.
Here it is.
On the top left corner, you
have a drop-down box menu
where you can select
the metric type.
In this case, it's the
GCM registrations.
Now, this metric means the
number of requests that
devices out there make to
register for this application
with the GCM servers.
On the top right, you can select
the period of time for
which you want to analyze
this metric.
And the tabs in the middle,
they allow you to do a
breakdown of this metric by
Android version, device,
country, language, and so on.
For example, here the breakdown
is by Android version.
And we can see that a majority
of requests come from
Gingerbread, ICS devices,
followed by Froyo.
We can go ahead and have it,
for example, look at the
application version tab.
We see we've launched
a few versions.
The last one is most popular.
And go ahead and go to the GCM
errors tab, which is going to
change its name soon, and
represent all the successful
messages and all the
error messages.
Well, in this case, we
had no failures.
But the best metric is
the GCM messages one.
If we look at the graph, we can
see that in the first week
of June, something happened.
All of a sudden, we started
delivering way more messages.
So either we rolled out a
feature or rolled out a bug.
And if you look at the Android
version breakdown, we can see
that the majority of messages
we send, they land on
Gingerbread, Froyo, and ICS
devices-- which is kind of in
line with what we've
seen with the
registration request metric.
We can look, for example,
in the country.
We see we launched in North
America as almost all the
messages that we send land on
users in US and Canada.
And finally, look at the GCM
messages status, which shows
the metrics I was
talking about--
sent, stored, collapsed, and
throttled, and invalid requests.
Which, in this case, they look
like to be the majority.
They are more than 70%
invalid requests.
So we can go ahead in
the GCM errors tab,
and see what's happening.
Very simple--
we all of a sudden started
sending lots of messages, but
we ran out of quota.
Now, the best way to fix this
is to migrate to GCM.
Now, I'm feeling a bit lucky.
And I'll try to give a live demo
of one GCM application
which all of you have been using
so far, which is the
Google IU app, and see how the
stats look like today in the
Android Developer Console.
Can you guys see, or should
I magnify more?
It's good?
This is GCM messages, and you
can see that on June 25 is
when we started to
deliver content.
We can see a majority of the
devices are ICS, Gingerbread,
Honeycomb--
weird.
Let's go to the GCM
message status.
And what we see is
that are sent
messages, stored messages.
But there are also a lot
of throttle messages.
Simple explanation, because when
we were testing this, we
started sending a lot of sync
requests, and then GCM decided
to start throttling it.
And the GCM errors, I want to
show you that, if we remove
the OK, we have Not
Registered errors.
We changed the version during
the past two days, so we had a
bunch of Registration
IDs in our servers.
And when we changed the version
and sent all the
messages, well, the old
registrations were invalid.
just figured it out.
And so we had massive errors.
And you can see that it's
steadily going down, and
tomorrow it will probably
drop completely.
One thing with this metric is
that they are daily metrics.
And they usually refer to
up to the day before.
Well, let's go back
to our slides.
So I said that to fix this
error, the best thing you can
do is to migrate to GCM.
Well, to be honest, it's
also the only chance
that you have now.
Because, as of now, C2DM
is in deprecation mode.
We do not accept sign-ups, nor
quota increase requests.
But do not be scared, because
the C2DM servers are still up
and running.
I was debating whether to kill
all your applications, but
then I flipped a coin.
I lost it.
But GCM servers are also up and
running, and they're very
much alive.
And I suggest you migrate
for two main reasons.
One, this service
is really cool.
And two, no, really, this
service is really cool.
And migrating is very simple.
Three simple steps--
click to enable GCM, point
your server to
android.googleap
is.com/gcm/send--
here, you want to use
the API Key--
and all you need to change on
the device is to register with
a Project ID.
But if you want to take your
time, you can do so.
We're not going to bring down
the servers for a while.
And you can read all the cool
new stuff we add in GCM.
Read our documentation, which
includes a Getting Started
Guide with a step-by-step
tutorial, with demo code,
which is open sourced, a demo
application, which is as well
open sourced with instruction on
how to use it and run it, a
quick-and-dirty guide for C2DM
experts on how to migrate, and
advance topics with pro-tips
on the rest of this
implementation.
And all this at
developer.android.com.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCESCO: So I hoped to land
a little bit longer so I
wouldn't get questions,
but I guess.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about multicasting.
Is there a way to send messages
to all devices
without specifying
individual IDs?
FRANCESCO: So the question is,
is there a way to do broadcast
of messaging?
I expected this question, and
the short answer is "no." The
longer answer is, it's a
very dangerous feature.
Every time I think about it,
it's like a big red button
that if you press it,
everything explodes.
We're doing our best, and we are
still thinking about it.
But for now, the best of your
options is to use multicasting
and add up to 1,000
in batches.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
possibility to send cloud
messages to applications not
installed from Play?
FRANCESCO: Second question
I was expecting.
It's pretty easy today.
Short and long answer-- "no."
The reason is GCM framework
relies on the Google Services
Framework, which is part of
the GMS core, which includes
Play and everything else.
It's a Google service, and we
will provide it only with
these other services.
AUDIENCE: I heard a rumor
that you don't have to
publish it in Play.
So if you upload it, and
not publish it, is
that going to work?
FRANCESCO: Yes, so, to use GCM,
you don't have to use the
Developer Console.
Is that the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
FRANCESCO: Yes.
What you're not going to
get is the metrics.
So to have access to all the
stats that we showed at the
end, you need to upload your
APK on the place on the
Developer Console.
But to use GCM, you
don't need to.
You just go to the Google
Developer Console, where you
have all the services, click for
the API, and you're done.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: For an app that
already exists, and we're
using C2DM, we know that when
we release an update, not
everybody's going to
get that update.
So we can't just switch it all
over to the GCM framework.
So do we have to keep two
separate systems, one
processing C2DM requests,
and the other one GCM?
FRANCESCO: For existing
C2DM applications,
the migration is--
well, you need to up the version
of the app, which will
have the Project ID.
And all the [? third ?] parties
on your server.
Now, you have to tell the
server, I'm using GCM.
So he knows to connect to
this new URL rather
than the old one.
That's all you need to do.
AUDIENCE: Basically we would
have to maintain our C2DM code
until enough clients
are off of that?
FRANCESCO: That is correct,
unless you want to kill all
your clients, yes, because
we changed the
authentication method.
But this is not just
forced by GCM.
Client login is deprecated, so
we had to switch away anyways.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So if I have an
application that relies on GCM
in order to synchronize, and
my messages expire after a
maximum of four weeks, what are
the circumstances where
the client receives the delete
message that says, hey, you're
way out of date, you need
to go and synchronize?
Is that only when messages just
get deleted, or are there
certain other kinds
of circumstances?
Can I guarantee-- can I
always rely on the--
FRANCESCO: All right, the
question is, if a message--
I'm repeating just to see if
I understood correctly--
if a message expires with a Time
To Live of four weeks, do
we get notified about the
fact that they expired?
No, because Time To Live means
simply that if the message
expired, the device doesn't
need to know that.
What I suggest to do, because
you're saying, well, if an app
doesn't connect for four
weeks, well, some of my
messages are deleted, right?
Well, four weeks
is a long time.
And what I would do is have
a full sync of my app if I
detect that for four weeks,
it's not been
connected to the network.
AUDIENCE: OK, good idea.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Is the Gmail sign-up
still required for Google
Cloud Messaging?
FRANCESCO: Gmail sign-up?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, at the
beginning, for a tour.
FRANCESCO: So to go to the
Google Developer Console, you
need a Google account?
AUDIENCE: No, not that.
I'm talking about
from the device.
FRANCESCO: No.
From ICS plus, you do
not need a Google
account on the device.
AUDIENCE: So, for example,
C2DM, you have to have a
sign-up for Gmail, right,
before it works.
Right now, you're saying that
it's not required, right?
FRANCESCO: It doesn't mean if
it's GCM or C2DM, it's a
change in ICS.
From ICS plus, you're not
required to add a Google
account on the device to be able
to use push messaging.
AUDIENCE: OK, one last thing.
What is the heartbeat, now?
What is the heartbeat rate?
FRANCESCO: For the persistent
connection?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
FRANCESCO: Well, it varies,
depends on the carriers,
depends on the countries.
The default classic value we
used is 28 minutes, but it's
changed a lot based on carriers
and countries.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I take it that this
means that it's back-ported to
at least Gingerbread?
FRANCESCO: GCM works
from Froyo plus.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thanks.
FRANCESCO: Of course.
AUDIENCE: What about the
security of the messages?
How is that going
to be handled?
So if I was sending account
information for a bank?
FRANCESCO: So if you add
information on the payload of
the message, well, the
connection between your server
and GCM server should
be HTTPS.
If you're comfortable with
that, then you can send a
message, and the connection
between the GCM server and the
device is secure, is encrypted
and whatnot.
But you can do your own security
on top of that and
encrypt your payload and
decrypt it down.
AUDIENCE: OK, and what
about the messages, I
guess, on the GCM?
Do they have a shelf life,
or does Google delete the
messages after a certain
amount of time?
Or are they kept for
x amount of time?
FRANCESCO: So the question is,
if you send a message, how
long GCM stores them?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and I guess, if
you send a message through
GCM, does Google hold onto that
message and keep it somewhere?
FRANCESCO: Right.
So unless you specify Time To
Live of zero, in which case
we're not storing it at all,
we store it for up to the
lifetime of the message.
If you don't specify, the
top is four weeks.
And we store it in our servers,
but we don't modify
the message or anything.
As soon as the device is online,
we just send it down.
AUDIENCE: OK, but I'm thinking
for a banking application.
If you're sending messages
through GCM, they might not
want those messages to be stored
on Google servers.
They just want it to be a
transparent pass-through.
FRANCESCO: Well, then the only
option you have is to specify
Time To Live of zero.
We do not--
AUDIENCE: And then nothing
will be stored on--
FRANCESCO: We do not store it.
AUDIENCE: OK, perfect.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if this
was mentioned, but can you
send messages from a device?
FRANCESCO: We have
an API for that.
It's not open to
developers yet.
We use it a lot for all
the optimization
I was talking about.
We are thinking to maybe
open it later on.
It depends on use cases.
So keep coming your feedbacks
and requests, and
we will back it.
AUDIENCE: And then
one more thing.
Is there any failure callback
for if a message fails
immediately or within a certain
period of time?
FRANCESCO: What type
of failures?
So if your request from your
server to our GCM server does
not fail, well then we ensure
delivery in the time span of
the four weeks.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Is there any chance to
use GCM for other devices,
like iOS devices, as well?
FRANCESCO: No.
The reason is we have a
persistent connection between
Android and our servers, in the
background, something that
you're not allowed to have
in other systems.
You can use APNS for Apple and
Microsoft Push, I think.
AUDIENCE: Second question, is
there some sort of time frame
delivery guaranteed?
Like say my server pings GCM.
What's the guaranteed time frame
it's going to reach my
device, considering that,
say, it is online and
available to GCM?
FRANCESCO: So we are
a very reliable
service, but we do not--
I don't want to say they
guarantee delivery.
It's a free service.
AUDIENCE: What if I need--
is there like a paid version
that I can get a--
FRANCESCO: Nope.
There's no paid version,
nothing.
All Google services and apps
use this as their reliable
mechanism to deliver messages
to Android.
It works very well.
But we just offer a free
service, and we have no--
we don't want to say we
guarantee delivery.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Would GCM be
appropriate for turn-based
game messaging?
FRANCESCO: A what game?
AUDIENCE: Turn-based game,
like a board game,
multiplayer.
FRANCESCO: Yeah, you know, if
you need very quick messaging
between two devices,
for example?
Well, you should open your
connection there, because you
want to keep up the
radio anyways.
Right?
So the main issue if you
use mobile networks
is the paging mechanism.
So let's say that you
have a device, and I
send you the message.
Even if I take those 4.7
milliseconds, well, now the
mobile carrier has to do the
paging, wake up the radio, do
the connection, reconnect the
socket, and send it down.
So that can take
a few seconds.
And radios go dormant pretty
quickly, because they also
want to optimize for battery.
So if you are in a
game modality--
so you want to keep the radio
up-- at that point why don't
you establish your own
peer-to-peer connection?
You can use GCM to create this
connection, to discover
something, but then--
AUDIENCE: Right.
And there's a way, I assume, to
say this message is OK to
be throttled, and this
other message
needs to never be throttled?
FRANCESCO: Well, you can
look at the stats.
You can not, for now, v1, see
a particular message, what
happened to it.
We're thinking to extend this,
and so that if you could put
the message ID--
which is what we return
in the response code--
and look what happened to the
lifetime of this message.
But for v1, you just see the
number of total throttled.
But as I said, throttled
messages happen only to very
small, super-powered users.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
FRANCESCO: Cheers.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
limitations around hardware
profiles, like a
Google-authorized Android
hardware device versus I take
the open-source version of
Android, do a build, and put
it on some independent
hardware profile.
Will this still work?
FRANCESCO: This works on
any device that has
the GMS core APK.
AUDIENCE: If I have a really
large number of messages to
send, is it possible to batch
a bunch of messages for
different destinations in
a single service call?
FRANCESCO: We don't have
localization API to offer.
This should be done by your
server that knows what you
want to deliver.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way to know
whether the message is
throttled or saved
and not sent?
FRANCESCO: Can you
repeat, please?
AUDIENCE: Is there a way for my
server to know whether the
message is throttled
or not sent?
FRANCESCO: Not yet.
As I was saying before, you can
see how many messages have
been throttled or stored,
whatever.
But for now, for a particular
message, we don't offer yet
that trace.
It's coming.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In your server code example, you
showed a bunch of Device
IDs that would get sent.
Is that required, or if the
devices are registering with
GCM, can you just not have
it broadcast to all the
registered devices?
FRANCESCO: Right, the
Registration IDs list allows
you to specify 1 up
to 1000 devices.
You have to say which device
you want to hit.
So you can put 1 or 1,000.
I mean 2, 3, whatever.
AUDIENCE: So, but you have
to put at least one?
You can't just say, all
registered devices will get
notified, right?
FRANCESCO: OK, so no.
We didn't offer a broadcast
feature.
That's what you want, is like
send to all [INAUDIBLE].
As I was saying to one of the
first questions, it's a very
dangerous feature for
us to provide.
Because if abused--
you know.
AUDIENCE: I see.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
Google services use this to
deliver messages.
Does the Google Talk
app use this to
deliver instant messages?
FRANCESCO: Google Talk
application--
it uses this channel, definitely
for down delivery.
And use also this channel
for upstream delivery.
Yes, it's the same channel.
AUDIENCE: So they use Cloud
to Device Messaging?
FRANCESCO: The next version that
we're going to be using
is Cloud to Device Messaging
like everyone else.
Talk, right now, it has its
own channel inside this
connection.
AUDIENCE: Will this work
on a Wi-Fi only device?
FRANCESCO: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: Will this work
on a Wi-Fi only device?
FRANCESCO: Yes, of course.
It actually works faster.
Well, if you guys have more
offline questions, I can take
them in the office
hours upstairs
in the Android section.
Thank you.